>> WERE YOU PREPARED FOR
THEM TO COME AFTER YOU?
>> I WAS PREPARED FOR THEM
TO COME AFTER ME.
BUT I WASN'T PREPARED FOR
THE PERSON COMING AT ME THE
WAY SHE CAME AT ME.
SHE KNEW BO.
SHE KNOWS ME.
I DON'T -- ANYWAY -- HERE'S
THE DEAL.
WHAT I DO KNOW -- AND THE
GOOD AND BAD NEWS.
AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK THEY
KNOW ME AND THEY KNOW ME.
>> Lawrence: FORMER V.P.
REVEALING HOW HE PLANS TO
TAKE DOWN DONALD TRUMP.
>> HOW DO YOU BEAT HIM?
>> I BEAT HIM BY JUST
POINTING OUT WHO I AM AND
WHO HE IS AND WHAT I'M FOR
AND HE IS AGAINST.
THIS GUY IS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
THIS GUY IS ACTING WITH
RACIST POLICIES.
THIS GUY IS ACTING TO FOMENT
HATE.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY CAN HE
SUSTAIN HIMSELF.
THE IDEA THAT I WOULD BE
INTIMIDATED BY DONALD TRUMP?
HE IS THE BULLY THAT I KNEW
MY WHOLE LIFE.
HE IS THE BULLY THAT I HAVE
ALWAYS STOOD UP.
TO SAY HE IS THE BULLY THAT
USED TO MAKE FUNNEL WHEN I
WAS A KID AND STUTTER AND I
WOULD SMACK THEM IN THE
MOUTH.
>> Lawrence: JUAN, HE TALKS
A TOUGH GAME BUT WHEN KAMALA
HARRIS HAD HIM AGAINST THE
ROPE HE SAID NO MAS
TIME-OUT.
>> Juan: HE GAVE THE
IMPRESSION HE WASN'T READY
TO BE CHALLENGED IN THAT
WAY.
IF THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S BIG TROUBLE.
HE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN AS THE
FRONTRUNNER, THERE WERE LONG
KNIVES READY FOR HIM.
THAT'S HOW OTHER PEOPLE WERE
GOING TO RISE AND CHALLENGE
HIM AS THE FRONTRUNNER AND
EXACTLY WHAT KAMALA HARRIS
DID.
SHE TOOK THE STAGE AND THE
REACH WE HAVE SEEN HER JUMP
AHEAD IN THE POLLS.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
THERE HE IS TRYING TO STRIKE
THE RIGHT TONE.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO BE TOO
AGGRESSIVE IN TRYING TO TAKE
HER OUT AND HE SAYS HE IS
NOT GOING TO PLAY THAT GAME.
MAYBE HE CAN HAVE HIS
SURROGATES, HIS AIDS, YOU
KNOW, PLANT STORIES AND GO
AFTER HER IN THAT FASHION.
BUT I THINK HE WANTS TO
REMAIN AS IF HE IS ABOVE THE
FRAY.
THAT HE IS THE FRONTRUNNER.
>> Lawrence: JOHN, HE WANTS
TO REMAIN ABOVE THE FRAY
UNTIL HE ACCUSES THE
PRESIDENT OF BEING RACIST.
HE PRETTY MUCH SAID IT RIGHT
THERE.
IS THIS HIS STRATEGY
EVERYBODY SUPPORTS TRUMP IS
JUST RACIST?
>> JOHN: YOU ARE PLAYING
TRUMP'S GAME.
TRUMP BECAME PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE WAS OUT THERE
THROWING HAY MAKERS.
YOU KNOW I THINK THEY THINK
THAT'S HOW THEY ARE GOING TO
BEAT HIM.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S HOW YOU
YOU ARE JUST PLAYING HIS
BALLGAME WHEN YOU STEP INTO
THAT AND HE LOVES THAT NOW
BIDEN IS HAVING HAY MAKERS
THROWN AT HIM.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE SEEN THAT
IN THE PAST COUPLE OF
ELECTIONS.
NOBODY TALKED LIKE THAT.
SMACKING SOMEBODY IN THE
MOUTH OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW, IT LOOKS LIKE TO
ME BIDEN I SAID THIS EARLIER
HE HAS BEEN LEFT AS IN HE
CAN'T GO -- I DON'T THINK
IT'S IN HIS NATURE TO GO
THAT LEFT.
BUT HE IS KIND OF OUT OF HIS
COMFORT ZONE BECAUSE IS HE
HAVING TO GO THAT LEFT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE SAME
CONVERSATION EVERYBODY ELSE
IS HAVING.
>> Anna: I THINK IN THAT
VIEW HE SORT OF SAID I'M NOT
AS FAR LEFT AS EVERYBODY
ELSE IS I HAVE BEEN IN
WASHINGTON.
I KNOW HOW TO GET THINGS
DONE.
I'M GOING TO MARINATE WHERE
I AM RIGHT NOW.
HE IS SITTING THERE IN HIS
LANE.
THERE IS NO WAY HE CAN RUN
AS AN OUTSIDER.
HOW LONG HAS HE BEEN IN
WASHINGTON.
IF HE RUNS ON SAYING I HAVE
GOT THIS PLACE FIGURED OUT.
I CAN GET THINGS DONE.
I'M THE ONE THAT'S LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE GENERAL
ELECTION TO BEAT DONALD
TRUMP RATHER THAN DEALING
WITH ALL OF THIS, THEN MAYBE
HE IS STRUCK A CORD.
LAWRENCE BLAWRNS HE
>>WRENCE BLAWRNS HE
>> LENCE BLAWRNS HE
>> LawCE BLAWRNS HE
>> Lawre BLAWRNS HE
>> LawrencLAWRNS HE
>> Lawrence:WRNS HE
>> Lawrence: HNS HE
>> Lawrence: HES HE
>> Lawrence: HE AHE
>> Lawrence: HE ADDRESSES.
SO POLITICS.
>> 80% OF YOUR PARTY CENTER
LEFT.
>> I AM CENTER LEFT:
>> DISCONNECT.
>> LOOK IT'S CENTER LEFT.
THAT'S WHERE I AM.
WHERE IT'S NOT IS WAY LEFT.
BY THE WAY, I THINK
OCASIO-CORTEZ IS A
BRILLIANT, BRIGHT WOMAN, BUT
SHE WON A PRIMARY.
IN THE GENERAL ELECTION
FIGHTS, WHO WON?
MAINSTREAM DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
VERY PROGRESSIVE ON SOCIAL
ISSUES AND VERY STRONG ON
EDUCATION, HEALTHCARE.
LOOK, MY NORTH STAR IS THE
MIDDLE CLASS WHEN THE MIDDLE
CLASS DOES WELL, EVERYBODY
DOES WELL.
>> Lawrence: TAMMY, IF
THAT'S THE CASE WHY IS HE
FLIP-FLOPPING ON EVERYTHING?
>> I THINK WHAT PEOPLE ARE
MISSING IS THAT HIS REACTION
IN AND OF ITSELF TO WHAT
MS. HARRIS DID REMINDS YOU
THAT THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A
REAL COMPETITIVE PRIMARY FOR
EITHER PARTY.
FIRST ONE WAS WITH TRUMP AND
NOW THIS ONE.
IS THAT HE DIDN'T EXPECT TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
HE DIDN'T EXPECT SOMEONE
ELSE IN THAT LINEUP TO SAY
SOMETHING HARSH OR TO MAYBE
TELL THE TRUTH OR WHAT THEY
SAW AS THE TRUTH.
BECAUSE, GOSH, THEY KNOW
EACH OTHER.
THIS REVEALS TO EVERYONE THE
FACT THAT THIS HAD BEEN KIND
OF A SHAM FROM THE BEGINNING
WHICH IS WHAT ALL AMERICANS
IN BOTH PARTIES HAVE
REJECTED AND HAVEN'T LIKED.
THIS IDEA THAT THIS IS
PREARRANGED.
THAT HE IS THE ONE THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO GET IT.
HE HAS THAT KIND OF
DEMEANOR.
NOW, I AGREE, THE DEMOCRATIC
VOTER IS NOT THE DEMOCRAT OR
THE LIBERAL ON TWITTER.
IT IS SOMEONE WHO IS MUCH
MORE QUIET AND WHO IS
WATCHING.
BUT THEN IF THAT IS THE
CASE, THEN HE SHOULD HAVE NO
PROBLEM.
BUT WHAT HE KNOWS IS THAT
KAMALA HARRIS IS GOING TO
CAST HERSELF AS THAT.
SO, HE KNOWS HE IS NOT
RUNNING AGAINST SANDY
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
HE IS RUNNING AGAINST KAMALA
HARRIS WHO IS GOING TO
SHIFT.
NO ONE IS GOING TO BE
RUNNING IN THE GENERAL AS ON
THE LEFT BUT THEY HAVE GOT
TO PANDER IN A CERTAIN WAY.
JOE BIDEN AND ULTIMATELY
WHAT PEOPLE DON'T LIKE AND I
DON'T THINK HE UNDERSTANDS
THE IRONY OF COMPLAINING
ABOUT TRUMP BEING THE
DIVIDER AND THEN TRYING TO
DISEMBATTLE HIM WITH HE IS A
RACIST.
I PUNCHED THESE GUYS IN THE
MOUTH.
NOBODY WANTS THAT AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S NOT
NATURAL.
WHEN IT'S -- WHEN YOU ARE
TRYING TO A PLAY A ROLE IN
CERTAIN WAY.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK IT'S
UNNATURAL GIVEN SOME OF THE
STATEMENTS TRUMP HAS MADE ON
RACE.
THE BIGGER POINT RIGHT NOW
IS WE HAVE ANOTHER DEBATE IN
THREE WEEKS.
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE A
HIGHER BAR AND IT'S GOING TO
BE TOUGH AGAIN FOR JOE BIDEN
BECAUSE HE LOOKED BAD COMING
OUT OF THAT DEBATE AND OTHER
PEOPLE MADE UP GROUND.
SO, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
LOOKING TO PUNCH AGAIN AT
JOE BIDEN.
HE BETTER FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DEAL WITH THIS.
MY SENSE IS THOUGH THAT JOE
BIDEN CLAIM AT THIS MOMENT,
TAMMY, IS THAT HE THE MOST
ELECTABLE DEMOCRAT RUNNING
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
>> EVEN ON THE ROPES.
>> Juan: EVEN AT THIS
MOMENT.
HE IS IN THE LEAD.
I THINK IT'S ELIZABETH
WARREN, I'M SORRY, BERNIE
SANDERS WITHIN FIVE POINTS.
>> Tammy: STILL, THAT'S
MISLEADING BECAUSE, OF
COURSE, THIS IS GOING STATE
BY STATE.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT MOST OF
THIS IS LIKE NATIONAL
APPROVAL.
IT'S GOING TO SHOW VERY
DIFFERENTLY AS THEY GO INTO
EACH STATE FOR THE
PRIMARIES.
AND THEN IT IS -- THE
DEBATES IS STILL GOING TO
MATTER.
THIS ATTITUDE.
>> I DON'T FEEL ABOUT
KAMALA'S REVERSAL ON THE
BUSING ISSUE BACK AND FORTH.
>> Juan: PRESSURE ON THE
LEFT.
ALL OF YOU GUYS SAYING ON
THE PANEL TODAY.
TO MY MIND, THE ONLY WAY WE
HAVE MADE PROGRESS ON CIVIL
RIGHTS IN THIS COUNTRY IS BY
DEALING WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE
RACIST VIEWS, TRYING TO WORK
SOMETHING OUT AND MAKE
STEADY PROGRESS THAT HAS
TAKEN US TO WHAT I THINK IS
THE BEST POINT IN THE
AMERICAN HISTORY FOR PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
SO,.
>> Lawrence: I THINK IT'S
PRETTY SHADY THAT SHE MADE A
CENTRAL ISSUE AND REVERSED
ON IT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Juan: WHAT DO YOU MEAN ME
REVERSED ON IT.
>> Lawrence: SHE WENT BACK
AND FORTH.
>> Anna: CAMPAIGN READY TO
GO.
>> Juan: NOW ON BUSING IN